hello and welcome to this video PT Capri
yeah that's a frequent opponent hmm yeah
a slight plus score nothing brilliant
though yeah ok let's go for the bull go
one more time yep that's a main line and
black has may be decent to equalising
chances here but why it is also also
decent here I think b6 is a movement a
couple of options 96 is also ok
ultimately I think ahead b6 in my book
i'm not mistaken yep 96 let's let's gain
gain a temple and queen age for Earth ok
go rook c8 try it for quick account to
play with 95 and I don't think oops take
back requested your pads I'm not going
to screw this game up with Katie one
take that accepting yeah that's uh
that's it's awful kinky one let's let
let him cancel or something probably
wanted to Castle
I think yet why is that it's a full take
back right I don't think he has to
Castle you can also play something
something else now however if he castles
isn't Knight a5 something something
decent here and i always taking a should
have form hmm interesting move huh I
still like 95 let's go there let's
blacks ID anywhere you trade in some
time for good development set right no
one's reading in the dark squared bishop
for some time and good development okay
interesting I can take with the rook I
think before this rook age five but
let's not be too quick um I think I can
do that will gauge five is a honey and
honey move
white person okay what kind of a
disastrous game sometimes yeah nothing
kind of works well together a very short
game but it's it's still I'm just
sometimes if I have a very short game I
just don't upload it but um reality
happens but I think this makes some
sense because it is actually quite
interesting um yeah what black is doing
here with this c5 he tries to open up
the position quickly white can also take
I had this sound also in a tournament
game once here I think black is very
often setting up some Hedgehog type of
position yeah in three tanks and the key
is that here Bishop takes d2 is entirely
impossible it just gives away the pawn
am so he has to take with the Queen and
this is taking quite some time after the
capture and after night at three b69 txt
for is not really that great as we
should be seven it's gam pausing and
pretty annoying question you can play a
three but this is not the greatest setup
ever like often gets in a quick opening
of the position maybe not immediately
but shortly yeah Bishop here push appear
and now Queen takes this is the
consequence you move the Queen quite a
lot and black in the meantime gets good
development going yeah and I to be
honest I have forgotten how this is
playing out this is definitely
definitely a position that I have
covered in my in my book very likely
Bishop g5 is correct I think and to have
this move we have rook c 1 and T I think
Mia black should be should be okay for
example I castles and then I go h6 next
that's a good good endgame public I mean
good
def playable okay equal nothing nothing
bro yet maybe age six also immediately
so that may be more precise can you do
this hi can actually take that's nice
some tactics in check yeah this is
probably not that great as c4 now is so
yeah it's basically gone if he goes rook
see one I can take it with the rookin
and like I can do a funky stuff like
that but well this is a problem I mean
maybe it's light compensation or why but
it's not convincing at all yeah this is
not just not working as i have this
google h5 thing which is easy to to
overlook but it's a funny way to to trap
the Queen early on route c 8 c 5 h 5 and
it is strapped yeah cannibal an off game
for the white player here but i think
i'm still quite interesting okay thanks
for watching